you should get your ass checked out no I
think I'm
good yeah that's the that's the dude way
right
there yeah I've had a hemorrhoid man
I've had Henry chilling down there for
years now really yeah actually he wakes
up every now and then oh but you're good
like it's just like flares up every now
and then yeah yeah well you remember the
story what
um I I went and got the check and you
shamed me cuz they're like would you
prefer a male or a female yeah I said
I'll go to the lady doctor yeah and
everyone shamed me they like that's
weirder yeah that's weirder I think it
is in what
respect like checking your [__]
yeah I guess I feel like a dude would be
more like sympath like it be like yeah I
know i' I got last thing I want is aown
man finger in my ass and he's being
empathetic to me he's like H sorry buddy
I don't want someone to say sorry buddy
while they got their finger in my ass
okay but like okay so if you go to your
like primary and then sometimes they
check your balls they have you cough and
do all that [__] is that a guy or a girl
uh it's a woman my my primary physician
is a woman really so I just said let I
just said let it ride huh and then I
found it doesn't really matter they like
they've seen it all yeah you know what I
mean but you know here I feel like even
with a girl it's like a you know it's
[__] sorry it's cold in here you know
I wouldn't
care I know I don't either but I'm just
saying like there is that sort of little
bit for the guy it's like I don't [__] I
actually don't care you know I mean I
just you know I
just a handful of meatballs and I just
faced away what do you mean what you're
talking about your junk yeah yeah no I
just you know I just grabbed it no but
they have oh yeah yeah but I'm saying
like just generally like when like for
your checkup oh yeah that person
sometimes they like check your yeah no
we've never uh we never we haven't gone
that far ah I see we haven't gone to a
medical fourth base yet yeah yeah yeah
uh no I just said let it ride but here's
what's really fun after she put her
finger in my ass I found out she put it
in your ass oh yeah do this for your
prostate or for your whole I got my
prostate checked oh you did cuz uh that
runs in the fam oh okay the PC oh I see
the prostate cancer I see so I went I
went for a twofer when was this it was a
little while ago I don't think you told
me about this oh yeah did you I thought
I did oh okay this happened years ago
okay but I went for the you know PC
check uh because I was I was [__]
sticks so maybe I should go I was
[__] bread sticks yeah and I'm like
dude do I have and then I you know I was
getting the blood okay and I'm like
maybe it's a hemorrhoid but you know got
to be safe yeah so she got in
there and she goes yeah it's just a
hemorrhoid we can schedule an
appointment to you know take it down but
the thing is like they can just get
agitated and come back so I would advise
just take care of it and you know kind
of Let It Rock I said sure I thought
that was the end of it and then I found
out 2 days later we live in the same
apartment complex when we were working
out in the gym
together no way and we had this little
moment where I'm like you've had your
finger in my ass and she's like yes I
have and you have a hemorrhoid yeah and
you have a hemorrhoid I know what your
ass look I know it's probably itchy
right now I know what it looks like when
you turn around and you hold your dick
and balls in your
boxers I know what the inside of your
body feels like
yeah I've been inside you she can say
that I've been inside you so you know
her bedside manner is awesome but I
didn't want some dude in there I don't
want a guy talking to me about what's in
my ass okay while digging around in
there you know cuz I had a I had another
physician who was a male he this vegan
guy uh plays guitar so he had like spiky
during the appointment yeah okay he's
like you got to stay away from the whe
protein stuff man no seed oils man is
number one thing I always recommend he's
just playing uh now he was I was
picturing him getting in there cuz he
kind kind of had this like dry like Ben
Stein delivery I was and I was just
thinking man that'd be I actually when I
think about it I just pictured him
talking too long yeah just digging
around in there just
like so uh yeah so it's starting to feel
like spinning too many
times it's getting
hard you got to
stop that's my
chees you might get a little uh reaction
there God oh I'm going to [__]
blow no I I just picture him like
forgetting you know yeah so what
neighborhood you live in oh man long
drive here this morning huh I always
feel like I feel like the 405 is always
kind of like jammed up around a stop I'm
going to come I'm going to come going to
come I'm going to come doc a you're good
yeah you're
[Laughter]
good it's a hemorrhoid yeah yeah or you
just sitting there chatting with
you and you're like are we done he's
like oh yeah sorry yeah yeah sorry yeah
you're all
right ah damn I should have seen that
coming
should have seen that coming takes off
his glove puts in the microwave turns
it 20 seconds beep all right you should
be
good really glad I talked about the
special in the first five minutes of the
episode I know [__] hit off at
20 man out of
here no this is good man a [__] this is
this is a good this is a good throwback
yeah you what talk about you know some
classic
TMG seriously we were making mother dude
I I I was reflecting on that the other
day how many people we made
crash yeah yeah throw up our podcast has
claimed so many cars man I thought going
to say Liv so I was like that's no no no
dark I honestly think I've always
thought it'd be really funny if we spun
up an insurance fund like if we had a
tear of the podcast that if you laugh so
hard you crash you can file a CLA we'll
try to cover up to a certain
amount Man actually or if you gag so
hard yeah yeah yeah yeah you can file a
claim and we'll just send you back a
picture of our diarrhea yeah yeah vomit
Insurance to see if we can get you to
complete we'll try to bring you to
completion no man I if you have gotten
in a car accident from the TMG podcast
um send the TMG account a photo of that
I remember back in the day so many
people would just I crashed on the way
over to this or your last episode got me
in a ditch yeah you know just shout out
to
you it' be awesome to have a slideshow
run where like this is in remembrance of
everyone's like [__] front headlights
yeah
yeah yeah all the car all the cars this
podcast has claimed I think our six year
anniversary is coming up right wow like
what next
week a few weeks from now six years it's
kind of beautiful just kind of crazy I
feel like f the fiveyear one just
happened it really did feel yeah it's
cuz I was gone for those 5 months yeah
so it just kind of wiped out time
yeah maybe that's it this is just a
classic poo poo
episode an absolute just a solid 55
minutes on [__] yeah a solid [__]
yeah wouldn't have it any other way to
be
honest